no I don't wanna play hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to night
Horrors now this isn't any horror game
that I don't know a lot about but I
believe it might be in the same vein as
a free roam five nights at Freddy's type
deal
oh hello well this looks moderately good
hi I remember people calling me at night
Inever hello amazing work of Freddy
fazbear's pizzaria of course we are
after the restaurant closed down we try
to salvage as matches of the
animatronics we could unfortunately the
main animatronics were promised to other
companies so fazbear entertainment
decided to give us two other characters
they had never been used by the
restaurant they didn't have names but we
decided to name him James fazbear's and
scrappy oh good
what playful names and concept model of
Freddy and scrappy shows the slide
resembles to Bonnie
since they have never been seen their
word of fortune that's why you're here
connect models from getting harmed or
stolen I'm sure you may be a little
worried about a models roaming but it
has never happened here like it has in
the biz area
the museum is currently still in
construction so we do not have much to
show but we are still working on getting
some more memorabilia from the owner we
have provided you with strong weaponry
because we always keep the interest or
walk through the time locking mechanism
so we will need it if someone bracing ok
my office is your safe place so me sure
if you do get attacked by an intruder
to keep yourself safe in there now try
not to stay in the office too long we
should ORS closed as door seems to start
malfunctioning if just burst that's all
there is to it so good luck and we will
see you about mainly the laughing hi oh
[Music]
hi are you scrappy or your who you James
fazbear's I like I won gets such a very
noble title and the other one is scrappy
oh hey Bonnie
so I was right this was one that was
sort of like a five nights at Freddy's
fan gaming oh my god it is dark in here
and oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god what's in here hello
Nicorette keycard what I have to escape
did I suddenly realize that this was a
bad situation to be in it that I
probably need to get the fudge out of
here ah know what I did zone a veneer
okay good okay you're still there
I've got my eye on you I'm gonna I'm
gonna just adjust my column here and
hopefully not die a horrible death Lee
death right okay
alright then we're gonna go with that
one we're gonna go with that's okay
we're gonna go if all that is normal
there and everything is hunky-dory in
la-la-land inside this bear Sam great
let's go back in again and see what else
is in this horrible horrible this that
we call this game okay I'm gonna
activate this sumbitch and you better
not come after me okay so how do I know
where he is I'm gonna call them scrappy
anyway I'm not gonna call him James
they're both gonna be scrappy just a
little bit perturbance sir wait what was
that at the bottom it's at future Island
what does that even mean for you it's my
brain power that's gonna get me through
this you know this to be true you can't
fight me on this one but you've
collected a new key okay
it's so quiet in here so none of em are
gonna be right now I'm gonna be
wandering here forever and ever
okay all right game now I don't know if
the game is bugged out and he's smoked
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how you want to play this no no I
don't wanna play what the [ __ ] do I do
he's just hiding better in the dark
it's it's gonna be every other
opportunity that he comes after me I'm
not gonna be able to survive this with
my sanity intact [ __ ] hell
I'm gonna give this one more go and
island I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die
here so maybe I could give him a scare
oh god why do they build this like a
[ __ ] maze
I'm too pretty don't kill me can't B's
contained no no scrappy are you better
wander off into the darkness I don't
like the fact that you can only hear his
footsteps if he's like two steps away
from you okay let's see what future
Island is oh hi there I've decided to
cancel Bennett talks as I realized that
this would be a bit too big for my next
project but since I would like another
project to work on that decide come over
something knows named it future Island
oh so there's the story similar to
androids and alien isolation Kickstarter
ex machina six hour long campaign sounds
pretty good so anyway that is night
Horrors if any of you guys want to try
to beat this I'll put a link to the game
in the description below but holy [ __ ]
that was awesome
that was terrifying but awesome but they
did a really good job here and I kind of
liked it I don't know if it's like it'll
be fun in the long run but what they got
here was pretty terrifying to me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know we think down the comments
below
in the next
[Music]